hey Brian what a do you ever have
nightmares about the the chicken
which one which a calm hot ones
oh isn't that bad Oh Sean Evans yeah I
don't know I I do feel like having
chicken though I just want like chicken
that's not [ __ ] up oh we got you you
do yeah I have all the ingredients
actually you wanna make him let's do
that yeah I'm making for you cool so I
can do it oh yeah
yo I'm rich Brian I'm Joe G and we're
celebrating the Adia rising head in the
clouds album and tour by cooking for our
friends at our end of summer party house
the thing is though I don't think we
really know how to cook
welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the fries mansion welcome to the feast
mansion
[Music]
yeah what's up this rich Brian this is
Joe G that's Joe G and we're about to
make Indonesian fried chicken and we
need some help because we're stupid
Jonny from Holland raised money doing
good oh yeah
right so she got a chicken okay all
right well pop it right here do you make
all this so yeah we serve this in
Chinatown Los Angeles California we use
some of the hottest peppers in the world
we'd like to kind of like flex a little
bit with Nashville hot chicken
specifically because you know it did
originate as a revenge dish oh really
today we're trying to burn people it's
kind of tight they were eating that's
good though cuz usually it's like poison
or something poisonous [ __ ] not not
him
yeah yes yeah so today we're gonna make
the Indonesian chicken I'm super excited
for this right but I mean I don't want
it to be like like it's not as like
[ __ ] up is it like could we go through
the levels I started with the baby
levels for you guys just so that we can
like graduate so mild medium and then
hot so definitely start work your way up
yeah let's let's try mild and then you
know see how spicy you want to make this
Indonesian trouble yeah let's give it a
try all right Cheers it Cheers mmm oh
wow that's really good mine right Wow so
how much money do you make how much
money I make no actually I Drive a Prius
man I mean apartment oh okay
well you're you're old enough to drive
right yeah but I just like I just don't
so hard to get a driver's license yeah
yeah he's just going all out you got
someone in white threes man please
you're sweating a little bit
do you want to dad oh yeah and Navya oh
thank you
knows no it's mine oh no what the [ __ ]
is going on thank you some people have
hyperactive sweat glands right yeah easy
it's like bears yeah big boys I like
that
so I'm done to make the mob wash my
office yeah yeah let's do it
yeah whoa I mean do you we do want like
now I'm curious we're here oh now look
here I'll take the one by about curious
why didn't you have this energy in hot
ones whoa whoa whoa it's like a Shawn
Shawn was making me nervous bro China is
the most intimidating guys very sexually
intimidating yeah man when I was in
Nashville in my coffee I would do it
four times a day
in my coffee I put pepto-bismol because
I was eating so much of this as research
you know cuz you have to understand it
Oh mmm that's abysmal and coffee coffee
makes me like poop and so pets of this
mall it's supposed to help with that
yeah I mean like solidifies it helps
it's like a coating think of it like
like holding the stomach this is
damaging that damn
like
you sweat now ya big pores
alright so we're making the mild one
definitely I'm making that one got it
yeah so ready we start can you do it
let's do it
[Music]
Indonesian style fried chicken
we got the raw chicken right here and
we're gonna make our marinade let's do
it are you ready so we've got some
really cool stuff here oh yeah this is
gonna be candlenuts okay all right got
the shallots and shallots Yeah right so
we got some garlic in there we're gonna
be nice and generous and then we got I'm
a I must say this I'm gonna try and say
it gall & gall honestly dude I don't
even [ __ ] know with that as that is
my first time like seeing that in my
life looks like a route we're really
lacing it with a lot of tumeric is I
feel like any Indonesian cooking you
know that's a very common is gradient
and ginger right here - and then we got
lemongrass I checked out your guys music
is pretty cool with other things thank
you I'm looking for slang I'm an old guy
really slang someone say it's on on
flick and I'm like Oh on fleek play
complete oh yeah I guarantee simply
Bopha both of us so if I'm like that I'm
like
Bopha yeah he's my favorite but these
exactly tamarind paste boom oh you
correct this it's good oh yeah and then
and then someone says deez nuts after
that so next step fellas we're gonna
light this baby up all right just turn
your on take it for a spin
all right go drive it you know press the
button I want to press the button Joey
I'd love to you know which one we're
gonna press off pulse No
okay right Wow it's very satisfying so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
really massage the chicken massage it in
there yeah
double-team this [ __ ] hmm didn't know
that we were gonna get to this point so
early I know ah this is gonna chill out
in the fridge it's gonna hang out for
about 24 hours
uh-huh what are we gonna do for 24 hours
I got I got you oh really
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we got it right yeah I'm looking
look it well it is all yellow now maybe
that it's kind of beautiful and that
dope it looks like they were just born
like that you know yeah Simpsons that's
what they did so far I'm here every
Wednesday so you ready to fry some
chicken yes
i'ma give you some pointers so my
grandma had a really nice trick actually
what's you fry stuff how she keeps him
crispy is she would literally put a
plastic bag in the oil a plastic bag a
plastic bag so whatever she was frying
the plastic bag we just dissolve and
just kind of a plastic bag the plastic
bag would fuse into the chicken yeah and
that's when you eat it huh that's what
makes it so you're eating the plastic
that fused to the chicken well as soon
as I find out that she was doing that I
stopped
wait is this I don't know gee I'm sorry
should we call someone yeah this is it's
all good what's your name I'm yeah her
name I'm not gonna say what I name is
[Music]
you just feel like savvy enough to be
able to put chicken in a cast iron with
your raging hot oil yeah all right ready
when you put it in go away from you okay
watch away all right okay do you feel
confident yep
can try drumstick do a drum we got four
wings in there imagine we serve a
thousand people
Jesus Christ do you guys had just
dramatic about it so look look at that
look at this that am i doing it
yeah hitting the spot yeah that's money
no flower you know oh wow
it's like look just delicate whoa just
no bubbles pop up when I guess [ __ ] no
fine now look this is like yeah it's
alive Wow yeah you go
this is [ __ ] I apologize it's right you
good and you you forgive me I forgive
you can I still work at your place we
got we got some training in two but yeah
check these out
yes chef thanks call-outs in the kitchen
when I asked yes chef yes chef yes chef
okay uh it's like strong all right yes
chef like order in two Sandoz yeah sure
honey
ja ratatouille you feel me
ratatouille - that's my life right there
yeah little rat look at it it's like a
cheap shot on you know there's a spot
here in LA shout out to I'm a butcher it
it's a meat markets at Carniceria yeah
on Santa Monica also shot at Owen Wilson
m2 what's that well I know who he did
but I need you to do he was just
shouting about in general fried the
chicken looks amazing can't wait to try
this but kind of wanted to take it next
level because I saw you guys made the
Sun well we appreciate and love this
crap yeah and we want to learn about it
more and we did our spin on it a little
bit of ghost pepper Oh laced it with a
few things like how and raise style yeah
and we wanted to kind of like serve this
to you guys with this because we found
that it's a typical accoutrement that's
generally served with indonesian food oh
you're [ __ ] me up right here Johnny
one I do three yes chef yes chef
oh oh and that is so fresh I'm like a
brown it's like you're off uh-huh
does a lot yeah all right so I just
tried the wings with the sambal and it
was amazing but right now I kind of want
to have that self see you know just like
the pure marinate I learn how to like
eat wings really fast oh you just like
hold it from here oh yeah just like whoa
shout out shout out to Brian that's that
was those bruises impressive you get
impress a lot of people that you know
that yeah but this [ __ ] tastes like so
good it's been so hard to like find you
know good authentic Indonesian food in
LA and like this literally tastes like
what my mom makes at like 6 p.m. at home
like every day I would just kind of like
go to the table late to the kitchen
counter and just like to find this and
it tastes just like it are you guys good
I'm not very poor at that really oh yeah
like like yeah I can do that huh oh yeah
just your knockers see oh he's good oh
okay guys you don't know what they're
doing but they're just like like what
are we doing yeah
oh yeah men watch ha all right one more
time let's go smoother come on ah and
see we're getting better all right you
practice with it wait does this ha it's
addictive right so you feel like like I
know you now Yeah right see it's getting
better to you God do that with all your
friends you got to get to know him
better we got history feeling this I do
when you look at me
take my Tyler take your clothes off one
more time maybe I can let you don't be
called it and impressing me
you can for me like a dress but you fit
better a novelty
we looked under
we geyser
[Music]